this video is brought to you by wicks
whatup wisecrack jared again and today
we're talking about the anime that isn't
sure humidity has much time that's right
we're taking a trip back inside the
walls and we're visiting attack on Titan
before we get started though a quick
shout out to us
and our first video an attack on Titan
we piece together all the German
sounding names like Noah Brody and the
vague political allusions to say that
attack on Titan was a show about a
concept in political theory called the
friend enemy distinction check that
video out but the TLDR is functionally
that this guy named Carl Schmidt said
that friends and enemies were a
foundational division in politics
without which some pretty bad stuff
would happen but we mused what if the
show is a critique of Carl Schmitt who
by the way is not a nice man and got
caught up with some bad stuff in the 30s
also we didn't read the manga and tada
that critique happened as attack on
Titan is progressed it became clear that
the Starks division between enemy and
friends ie Titan and human is a pretty
intense fabrication used to advance a
specific agenda seasons 2 & 3 explore
what happens when that distinction
begins to crumble
oh no you already got the wood thing
can we just patch up society and go home
well not quite that's because as the
show explores even when the truth is on
your side society has some great defense
mechanisms to uphold the status quo so
strap on your ODM gear and join us as we
go deep on attack on titan seasons two
and three and as always spoilers ahead
first up want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Wix Wix is the easiest
way to create beautiful professional
websites for whatever your needs may be
I'm actually trying to get into the
professional voice-over game so I
created a website with Wix to present
all my voice samples so check it out I
was creating website for myself and I
wanted a portfolio and CV and I'm a
total noob
then I literally started typing and
there was already a template for
voiceover artists I picked a style I
liked and within minutes I was dragging
and dropping my audio files and bam now
I have something I'm confident to send
out to potential clients establishing
yourself as a professional in a new
space can be daunting but I was really
surprised by how inviting and easy it
was to create a website that makes it
look like I know what I'm doing
so if you're looking to up your game
before 2019 go to Wix calm slash
wisecrack or click the link in the
description just
making your free website today and now
back to the show
let's start with a quick recap attack on
Titan is about the last vestiges of
humanity hiding out behind giant walls
to avoid naked man-eating Titans as you
might imagine with giant monsters on the
outskirts of your walls a pretty
rational us-versus-them structure
society this is a pretty high-risk
lifestyle and sure enough Titans break
through the outermost wall from there
things go from dire to downright
dystopic and it's up to the scouts
mankind's outrider strike force to get
under control but like the city's walls
the stark division between human and
Titan doesn't last very long at the end
of season one the scouts realized that
one of their own Aaron and shape-shift
between human and Titan also he might be
able to use his Titan power to seal that
pesky hole in the outer wall George in
Costa Allegra Cole Kazuki unknown
ordered a cabin on a soggy note a to
stop in season two a bunch of Titans
emerge and trap the scouts in a castle
or fellow scout yamir turns into a Titan
surprise to rescue them apparently
everyone is a Titan as Berthold and
Reinert are in fact the colossal and
armored Titan respectively
they kidnap Eren but the scouts are able
to rescue him and start laying out their
plan to fix the wall Eren learns he can
control nearby Titans and we learn that
this lady Christa is actually named
historia which is very important then a
season three happens Erwin the commander
of the Scout stages a coup d'etat by
turning the people against the nobles
Scouts Eren and historia are kidnapped
by historias father the true king rod
rice they escaped but not before rod
rice becomes the grossest Titan to date
he attacks the city but Aaron and his
story achillion cementing historia as a
warrior queen the people can get behind
finally United that people can get back
to retaking the outer wall whoo okay
now we're all caught up but what do we
make of all that well as we mentioned
attack on Titan has always been about
the distinction helping a friend an
enemy and regular speak it's the idea
that the easiest way to get society to
work together
is if they're against someone else well
season one showed a whole society built
around this principle seasons two and
three explore how people empower
knowingly manufacture this false divide
as such attack on Titan is a show about
the flow of information
each episode includes an interstitial
labeled information available for public
disclosure which implies a trove of
information not available to the public
some of that classified information
includes the Titan inside the wall
brother Nick a priest of the wall might
know something about it but he gets got
by the interior police before he can say
too much and when a young urban talks
about some of his father's theories on
history in public well let's just say
that no one has to worry about waking
daddy anymore another critical secret is
the fact that some of these psycho
killer Titans are in fact just
shape-shifting people Aaron is the first
example we meet but at the end of season
one we see Annie shape-shift and in
season two yamir Reiner and bertolt all
transform we even see a town where most
of the population has changed into
Titans home gracious again stop judging
the show tiger no come on I'm assuming
of course this is a critical secret and
one the nobles will do anything to keep
under wraps that's just the tip of the
conspiratorial iceberg behind the
already repressive government there's an
even more autocratic system that exists
in the shadows it turns out that the
king we thought was in charge is just a
figurehead instead the city is ruled by
the rice family currently rod and his
heir Astoria who have the royal blood
necessary to control the powers of the
founding Titan salutes canola Lisa okay
no choice kimono tonight torsion what's
got in the hot tea Serena powers like
changing the memory of the citizens and
even creating the walls I know some
journal kaboom also no children not you
gonna down all of that is happening
behind the scenes determining the fate
of the people who have no idea it even
exists the nobles go to great lengths to
keep the secret government secret this
includes orchestrating a series of
attacks with the dual goals of
kidnapping Aaron and historia for the
sake of broad Rice's plan and framing
the scouts for acting against humanity's
interests they don't go in on Jude I
know you have no meat on me
then chores are here
why frame the scouts because between
seeing several different people turn
into Titans they realized that the
founding myth of their society that
Titans are unthinking people eaters is
in fact alive hmm
who knows you can go no Hoss no no nor
does anyone bother to mention the role
Titans played in constructing the walls
that define the world for most of
humanity oh you've got a mom would it
take almost every choice the show makes
is premise on the withholding or
discovery of information a double
identity dad a guy well nigh about da
tales Shinji that idea is so central to
the show it's embedded into the
narrative structure attack on Titan is a
mystery box show where the primary
driving force the narrative is moving
from one secret to the next rather than
moving along a narrative arcs it's a
difficult balance but so far the show is
pulled it off by putting the audience in
the scouts shoes just as Aaron and Co
have to decide who to trust and what to
believe
so do we as we watch the more we learn
the more we understand but the more
questions we have and same with the
scouts but this doesn't mean people are
kept totally in the dark
rather the information people do get is
designed to lead them to conclusions
that support the system as is to that
end there is a newspaper that provides
information to the population
unfortunately the only report with the
interior police tell them they should -
oh can you do this process of giving
people enough information that they
don't bother to question the structure
providing it or the world they live in
is described by scholar who mean Dabashi
as epistemic and osmosis where older
models of government assume the lower
classes were unthinking illiterate
idiots who wouldn't even know what to do
with the truth Dabashi argues that power
can be solidified by providing bad
information to the thinking and literate
people of the world Dabashi explains
that this is information to consume not
question furthermore it's not meant to
generate a coherent body of knowledge
but is instead sing
serving meant to induce action for a
specific event an attack on Titan we see
this in the form of state propaganda and
city newspapers that give people enough
information that they feel like they're
making decisions when instead they're
being manipulated
now while in the real world this kind of
epistemic andaaz Moses generates new
knowledge on demand for whatever
benefits those in power want on a given
day and has a pretty singular purpose an
attack on Titan to maintain the myth of
the Titan as outsider monster that story
enables those in power to justify almost
any action in the name of defending the
people from the monsters outside the
walls actions like rationing food
limiting people's movement you know Mew
none and even attempting to execute her
win' who's a goddamn hero
but why lie about the Titans in the
first place well it varies from
character to character but there are two
main reasons power and belief as for
power the city with a three wall
designed to protect against Titan
attacks also happens to be based on a
strict class structure that enables the
nobles cushy lifestyle they work to
perpetuate a stratified City suffering
from resource shortages and the
occasional make a giant incident because
it's that status quo that keeps them in
mansions and fancy robes
when urban orchestrates a false alarm
about a Titan attack the nobles don't
hesitate to bar refugees from the inner
wall Jimmy knows you know so you see job
in a small book we see that their
interest in the system has nothing to do
with protecting the people it's all
about protecting themselves without the
myths that control society someone might
get to thinking that having a bunch of
disconnected rich dudes in charge might
be a bad idea the other more complicated
reason is belief this idea is most
clearly manifested in the character of
Rod Reise Reise sincerely believes that
the only way to protect the people is to
use the power of the founding
you know Covino ii scripted a decent
olga georgian is a little sick I you
know zonda kureta sora sora co so casino
hey vidhata suit steve even if that
means wiping people's minds and having
his daughter eat her friend to become a
Titan herself with all those fancy
powers Cousteau that power is so crucial
to maintaining the status quo that rice
thinks there's no price too high to pay
for it even his own daughter
thus when she rescues Aaron he takes the
serum himself to try and inherit the
power but it goes awry and he almost
kills everyone
what makes this dynamic extra
complicated is rod didn't always believe
this as a younger man he and his brother
Yuri wanted to destroy all the Titans
but when you regained the founding
Titans power he changed his mind and
concluded that only the city could
protect them no matter the motivation
the problem with this hyper zealous way
of thinking is that it turns all
political questions into ethical
questions the war was changed for rod
rice whether he's trying to destroy all
the Titans are maintaining the myth of
the Titan the stakes are the existence
of humanity the earth Chantal moof
explains that when politics become a
referendum on ethics the politics part
ceases to exist in favor of a battle
between us and them the process is
simple an attack on titan the status quo
is set up as the only way to protect
humanity from the Titans that means
anyone opposed to the system represents
an existential threat that's oh hey hey
okay sorry less and thus they're evil
and when it comes to evil there's no
reasoning with it the only option is to
fight for instance when the city turns
on the scouts it's because these former
heroes put society in danger by
questioning dogma
so the scouts need to be destroyed the
ultimate existential threat and ethical
enemy according to the
fat cats and meet RIS district is the
Titans of course we know that's not
entirely true
after the scouts discover Connie's
village to be empty they realized that
many of the people there turned into
Titans including Connie's mother but
that doesn't matter in the face of an
ethics when some people or Titans are
determined to be an existential threat
the idea of understanding them goes out
the window instead it's time to grab the
swords and slice some vital areas the
Titans exist as threats to justify the
status quo and things to destroy as a
gesture towards safety that dynamic is
maintained by the control of information
of course but that monopoly starts to
come apart on the personal level
characters are constantly forced to
choose between promises they made to
friends or themselves and the broader
lie fueled social obligations some
characters have no issue rejecting the
morals provided by society in the name
of their own beliefs
for instance historia is unconditionally
loyal to a mere even though she's a
Titan at the same time Eren is driven
almost entirely by the hatred of titans
chose uep noticed and others are torn
between these obligations constantly
like the titans serving in the scouts
Berthold Reiner and Amir Burt field and
Reiner love their fellow soldiers but
are also bound to their duty as warriors
they're willing to capture Eren but at
the same time they do end up letting him
go then they end up with the Beast Titan
setting a trap for Aaron in the scouts
so human will dose you'll use him tools
in them
Cocco them up today uh Scott on Kunda
see they are pulled in two directions at
once constantly switching between the
two of course nothing an attack on titan
is simple so the show is saying more
than sometimes the rules of society
conflict with personal commitment
instead attack on titan makes it clear
that as the social structure loses
legitimacy whether through its failure
to protect the people or its myths
crumbling social bonds grow as the
scouts discover the truth their
connections solidify to the point of
trumping their societal obligation
that's why they go to rescue Aaron and
historia even as society turns against
them perhaps no other moment illustrates
this point better than Aaron and
historias confrontation in the cave rod
rice has Aaron chained up and offers his
story of the Titans serum if she takes
it she will transform eat her friend
Aaron and become the founding Titan that
rod rice believes the city needs Aaron
wants her to do it he thinks if she eats
him she'll be able to not only protect
the people but kill the Titans Aaron
spouts the city's myths at historia to
convince her Lionel mates and Sabine
but she's not buying it she doesn't
believe any of the social myths anymore
not just because she knows the truth of
the system
she knew nothing but she also sees the
moral truth any social arrangement that
puts her in opposition to her best
friend Amir is inherently wrong to her
you meet
nanny got
so she rejects Rob's plan smashes the
vial and Fries Aaron Aaron is arguing
for the status quo while historia
believes in the possibility of a better
different world these are the real
stakes of personal obligation versus the
ethics provided by society personal
ethics want to protect the values of the
people while social ethics are designed
to sustain the status quo attack on
Titan the seasons two and three point to
the dire fact that history can be used
as a tool to tell the story that ends in
the status quo that's why it's so
important that the founding Titans
powers include the ability to wipe the
memory of the population by creating a
history that fits their needs the people
in charge are able to maintain
persistent control of the population and
give them ethical priorities that match
the goals of the system an attack on
Titan society is sustained by myths the
powers that be will do anything to
protect those stories and justify the
status quo against the possibility of
any other social model career aagama
mauritania jindo a demonic career on
Doheny Otsuki no yeti cheetah moo shu
jimin Ticino ken de gobierno narada
Sana'a Haga Doretta roto virus that
includes killing titans even if they
aren't monsters after all but rather
people and during a terrible fate
anything is justified if it means
keeping society as it is intact so what
do you think wisecrack is attack on
titan a lesson on how power works or is
there something we missed
share your thoughts with the world or
create your own professional website by
clicking here to create your own free
website with wigs also we got some great
videos coming out before the end of the
year including ones on It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia the Justice League and
one on j.r.r tolkien that we were
working on for a while so stay tuned for
that and until next time peace